alicia what's going on hey there how are
you doing today i'm good how about you
i'm doing good i have um a question
obviously so i am divorced and me and my
ex-husband co-parent very well
together and recently he's basically
been living in my third bedroom
which is good for the girls and
everything but
i feel like they get more time with him
um but i feel like i need to create
boundaries
with it like between us because it is my
home yes
um on how to do that
it's kind of like um we eat taco bell
three times a day
every day for a year and i think that i
probably should start eating better
that's kind of what you're asking me so
do you have your uh um how long you have
been divorced
um we have been divorced for over a year
we were legally separated for
two years before we got divorced okay so
y'all haven't been together for three
years
we well he was still living with me when
we were separated
it's a very strange situation but he was
still living with me we ended up getting
divorced he moved out and then it's just
kind of like been a transition of him
being more present why
why did you get separated and then
divorced but stay roommates
um for the girls and like i feel like a
part of us was trying to work
on the relationship but which part of it
which part of us
the you part um yes
yes but ultimately is because
it just gave him more accessibility to
our children like he just
it allows him to have more time with
them
um is this a way for
you to keep him in your life yes
absolutely
okay and if he had to go find his own
place to live would he disappear
um no he wouldn't just fear i'd still
see him i mean
it would it would just be different i've
lived with him pretty much my entire
adult life so it's a strange thing
like when he's not there if i guess i
could say yes and
are you willing to cash in on any future
romantic relationships any future growth
any future movement you're gonna have
any semblance of a healthy relationship
model for your kids
in order to keep things the way they've
been forever
yeah and that's what i think about
because it's like this isn't how this
isn't the example i want to set and it's
just kind of
i don't know where to go from there yeah
it is it's example i love your heart but
it is the example you are
setting right yeah yeah um when's the
last time y'all slept together
um recent times yeah okay
so what does what does divorce even mean
it sounds like y'all are dating and
you're
honestly just sounds like a mess yes
it's yeah i mean i think the divorce
part was just
like the legality of well we're no
longer legally combined
um so it's like in theory there's the
freedom to go
date and do these things it just doesn't
happen
does he date around nothing i'm aware of
i know he had
like when we were separated but not that
i know of recently
oh man okay so
yeah you got to get him out of your
house and you've got to move on with
your life
and what's happening is how old are your
are your daughters
they are they're three they're twins
three year old twins okay
um you either need to decide this is
gonna be the guy you're with and he's
gonna decide
that you or the woman he's with um
or you are dancing with something where
he's gonna come home one day
and have been dating somebody for six
months and you didn't know it
or he's going to come home and have
something real serious
or you're going to run into something
real serious or he's going to get
transferred out or he's going to get
tired of just being with the kids and
he's just going to move
or you're going to get a job opportunity
or get transferred to some other
whatever is going to happen and all you
are doing right now is
um you know when you like uh i'm just
projecting out here but when you first
realized we're about to get divorced
and that extra that fourth fifth and
sixth beer made all that go away for an
evening
and then you had to deal with it
tomorrow that's what y'all are doing
right now
yes and the difference is you're
dragging
two three year olds along here and not i
guarantee i trust holy that y'all
um are doing well co-parenting
but you're playing house and your kids
are gonna pick up on that
tension on those comments on that gap
between you two
and they're gonna think that is how
normal functioning healthy adult
relationships work where two divorced
people
live in the same house date other people
one just dates
the other but the other dates other
people and they make sure everybody know
all
you know what i mean there's no yeah
there's no romance there's no dates
they're not seeing how somebody who
loves their mama treats their mama how
mama
treats dad they're not seeing any of
that they're just seeing two roommates
who occasionally hook up
and by the way kids can feel that and
that awkwardness the next day all of
that they're absorbing it
why are you terrified to leave him do
you still love him
i do yes i think the party will always
love him that doesn't mean i should be
with him i guess
okay so why i 100 honor that
right and i think you're right i think
there'll always be a party who cares
about this guy no question about it
um if he asked you to marry him today he
just came home this evening and said
what are we doing let's get married
would you say yes
truthfully i don't know why not because
i think about because i have those
moments where i miss like the romantic
relationship but i think about like
there's a reason why we're
not together like there's a reason why
and why not divorce
why'd you get divorced um
ultimately i had an affair years ago and
we never recovered from it
and there was just forever like anger
and tension towards each other
and we just never really recovered i
mean we get i mean we get along well
but it's like when it comes to the
romantic part it's like it just changed
and it's like we fought we fought a lot
so you deserve to have somebody who will
forgive you in your life and love you
for who you are
mistakes and all and if that's not this
person you need to move on
okay you got to move on you screwed up
years ago yep you did
and yeah the more you carry that around
with you
and the more that he weaponizes that and
uses that as reason to not
either fully love you or fully move on
all it's just a mess
right and what i'm telling you is this
only gets
this only ends badly it doesn't end well
because y'all are sitting on top of an
unhealed wound
that he has chosen and it's to some
degree you have chosen to never heal
from
and it's going to eventually erupt
and that's a gross analogy i know
because i don't want to talk about
erupting wounds
but it's coming your way and the mess
from all of that the pus
and the blood and the infection's gonna
get all of your daughters don't do that
to them
and don't do that to yourself right
yeah that's is that fair
it is fair it's just a scary i guess to
think about sometimes but yes that is
fair
do you think you're worthy of being
loved yes
yeah i would like to think so no no no
do you think so
yes you are are you are you a forever
are you a cheater for the rest of your
life
no not at all did you screw up once
yes absolutely okay here's what learn
from that
here's what i want you to do i want you
to
take out a piece of paper and i want you
to write cheater
on it with a marker okay and then i want
you to fold it up in an envelope
and i want you to mail it to me
and when you mail it you're done with it
you're done okay you're finished i can
do that okay you can look up my address
on the website i want you to mail it to
me
you're done with it okay and
you have to move on you have to forgive
yourself you got to put that thing in
the mail and send it away it's oh
it's over it's going to become a brick
on the new road
to wherever you're headed it's in your
past it's what it was
but until you forgive yourself for what
you did you're never going to think
you're worthy of being loved
and then you're going to let knucklehead
hang around in a third bedroom
sleep with them when you both get
exhausted and desperate or just need
human connection
and it's going to be easier than dating
especially during covet and you're going
to be able to lie to yourself and say
we're doing such a great job
co-parenting and what he needs to do is
get his own apartment get his own place
and still be
super present in his daughter's lives
that's his job not yours
okay yeah you know what i mean yes and i
try to make it my job or
my yeah i try to facilitate it you
act absolutely and you still will need
to be a
super connected facilitator right super
connected co-parent
but he needs to move on with his life
and take care of his new romantic world
and yours
and if he says no no i don't want to go
i've fallen back in love with you
then you'll need to zoom direct do not
pass go
to a marriage counselor deal with the
past infidelity and then move on
how long ago is that years um
this will be it's been five years ago
yeah done we're past it
we're on we're way past okay
it's heal and or separate heal and or
come closer together
build something new together and
something strong and then we're done
okay
so i want you to put that in a envelope
mail it to me and when it's
when you mail it never again you're done
with it it's over
it's something stupid you did in your
past and you're moving on okay
and then y'all are either going to build
something new or you are going to
scratch the
excavate that sucker and he's going to
be out so i would tell him
tonight this weekend hey listen we can't
keep playing house
we're divorced you need to get your own
place i need to move on with my life
i'm worthy of being loved um you're
worthy of being loved and we've already
determined it's not gonna be between the
two of us
these girls are learning an unhealthy
model of what
this wacky weird arrangement looks like
we're gonna co-parent awesome i'm always
gonna love you you're always gonna love
me and then we're gonna move on their
lives and we are gonna be the best
co-parents to these daughters
in the whole wide world and when he
falls in love with somebody
she's gonna be a great um
influence around your daughters or she's
not coming around them and when you fall
in love with somebody
that guy's going to be a great influence
around your daughters or he's not coming
around right and we're all going to do
this messy
gravelly uncomfortable walk together
but we're going to make these we're
going to pave this road with these
bricks that we're setting down we're
going to quit carrying that crap around